now the book is war in the west
but speaking of racism racism towards
different groups based on their skin
color you've said that there's a war on
white people in class
would you say that's the case would you
say that there are significant
um
racism towards white people in the
united states i'd say that the white
people in the united states are the only
people who are told that they have
hereditary sin
but that's a big one just to start with
based strictly based on their skin color
i mean i would find it so repugnant
if and i hope everybody would join me in
feeling this i would feel so repugnant
if there were any school of thought in
america today that had any
um
grasp on the public
attention
that said that black people were born
into evil because of something their
ancestors had done
like they had the mark of cain upon them
i mean i think it would be
such a
vicious way to try to demoralize
a group of people
and to tell them that
the the things they would be able to
achieve in their lives are much lessened
because they should spend
significant portions of their lives
trying to atone for something they
didn't do
is there a
difference and and and the following
point the obvious point left hand said
but let's say it
nobody
in the public square
says that i mean they're the maniacs of
the far fringes but nobody
in the mainstream would dare to say that
or i think even think that about any
group of people other than white people
and
does this mean that white people are
more disadvantaged than black people
know and again let's not make this a
competition but
let's not get into i just desperately
urge people not to get into the idea of
hereditary sin according to racial
background
is there something to be said about the
feature aspect to sort of play devil's
advocate
about
the asymmetry
of um sort of accusations towards the
majority so yes because
so much easier to attack a majority it
is much easier but is there something to
be said about that being a useful
function of society that you always
attack
um that the minority has
disproportionate power to attack the
majority so that you can always keep the
majority in check
it's a dangerous game to play isn't it i
think
it's very dangerous
that's a good summary of entirety of
human civilization well yeah
everything's dangerous um
but it's a very dangerous game to play
that i wrote about this bit in the
matters of crowds when i was saying to
like
gay rights people the ones that still
exist the ones who don't have homes to
go to
uh who
want to beat up on straight people in a
way
or want to make straight people feel
like they're
kind of unremarkable uncool
you know
boring straights
so boring
so not not like the magical pixie fairy
dust gaze
um that's a bad idea to push that one
that's a bad idea and some gays push
that
highly unwise
given the fact that about
two to three percent of the population
are actually gay although now there's
like a additional 20 who think they're
like two spirit or something and
all that [ __ ] but
they're just
attention seekers so let's not spend too
much time on that
but
equally as i've said i said the man is
the crowd with
with the feminist movement very unwise
for half of the species to say that the
other half of the species isn't needed
and there were always third and fourth
wave feminists willing to make that nuts
argument
uh
not first way famous you didn't hear it
in first wave feminism you didn't hear
suffragette tended not to say
we'd like the vote and men
are scum
and it would have been hard to have won
everyone over to their side not least
the men they needed to win over their
side
but you do get third and fourth wave
feminists who say like you know do we
need men
or men are all x again it's a bad idea
it's a bad idea tactically
what if men
richard rangham
somebody from harvard
uh describes that men
are the originators of violence physical
violence in society and he argues that
actually the world would be better off
no just a very cold
calculus if you get rid of men there
would be a lot less violence in society
is
his claim who says you need to get rid
of violence in society
well that's but shouldn't that at least
be a discussion
have a debate on a panel discussion
violence pros and cons well that's the
sort of thing if i can say so that
something weak ass academic decides to
do because he thinks that his area of
boston would be nicer or whatever
um
he might decide it's useful if he was
living in kiev today
to have violent men
i mean it might
if if um if new york was invaded right
now i'd need some violent men around
here
but it wouldn't be invaded
if there's no violent men
well that's the argos argument there's
there's also at least there's some level
of
threat
that you ought to exude that puts people
off
if i was in
you know i'm very glad that the men and
women of ukraine are capable of and
more than capable of fighting for their
country
and for their neighbors and their
families and much more but
like it's better that that there was
violence ready to unleash when violence
was unleashed upon them than that the
whole society had been told that they
should identify as non-binary
but at least it's a conversation to have
isn't there
uh
is there aspect to the sort of the
feminist movement that is correct
uh you know in challenging the
some forms of violence domestic violence
for instance
although women are capable of that as
well
i'm learning about this
in the moon
i can't help but watch the entirety of
it go down in this beautiful mess that
is human relations okay but just to
finish that thought i mean it's
it's very unwise for women to war
against men
as it would be for men to war against
women it's highly highly unwise to war
on a majority population and in america
britain and other western countries
white people are still a majority
and so why would you tell the majority
that they're evil by dint of their skin
color
and think that that would be a good way
to keep them in check
i mean i'm not guilty of anything
because of my skin color i'm not guilty
of anything my ancestors didn't do
anything wrong
and even if they had why would i be held
responsible for it
you